hello welcome to big mood yes a mood and
we are big personalities Irving yeah
personalities are big okay look oh my
body's a big word it counts what sucks I
got already decently sized big behind
how about you do you should hey we
should take like any arm fan put into my
boobs like baby seriously I'm so awesome
back here yeah the me it's my but I want
that but putting that but I want both
theories butts put together the other
like one but per cheek will take a cheek
from each and they will share it once me
just combined bodies cuz you got each
one of you got boobs mr. Potato Head
yeah we don't even think about the head
part yeah no one cares we wanted to talk
today about [ __ ] that we would tell
ourselves in high school or 20s era you
know we're young you know what we were
young what we would learn where we
learned now to impart wisdom wise on to
our younger selves in different areas
because I feel like that's the majority
of questions that we get asked is like I
should we just like go through the
timeline just be like and tell yourself
don't date that one don't date that one
oh my god don't be that way I'll be like
well that one's got a good dick so like
couple nights yeah I'll get that one
experience is a experience thing we're
actually talking about this over the
weekend TIFF was saying something like
if you could get a preview into what
your relationship would look like while
you're dating that guy if you could kind
of see a preview trailer of what it was
gonna look like would you still or would
you want to do that or would you still
date them my answer was I would not want
to see that trailer because I would
probably say no to most of the
relationships that I've had
but actually going through those
relationships made me who I am today so
I would still do everything in my life
the same exact way and I'm gonna start
my advice with that but it would be nice
to like know how to deal with things
through I was thinking coming into this
video like this episode I'm like
honestly I wouldn't give myself advice
in terms of like what not to do or like
change certain events of my life because
I like even like the shittiest of the
shittiest events in my life like it just
has molded me to be Who I am but I think
for me the advice I would give my
younger self is more like internally
like self-love like be kinder to
yourself and like like just like walk by
the mirror and tell yourself you're
beautiful cuz I was [ __ ] mean in my
head I was like the meanest person ever
to myself and if I had that small shift
like I I think I would have turned out
to be a lot different
but even that stuff doesn't it make you
a little bit more empathetic towards you
know people you kind of get why they
feel that way or how and then it's you
know even that's tough I feel like has
helped me relate to people and like give
them advice I'm the same way I I really
I tried to live my whole life without
any regrets there are different things
that I would tell myself advice wise but
as far as changing anything I wouldn't
when it comes to relationships
specifically I think that I almost feel
bad for people that found a good
relationship right away because yeah
they don't fully appreciate or at least
the ones I've met don't seem to fully
appreciate it and they'll [ __ ] about
little things that really I don't think
are that big of a deal and so I am glad
that as shitty as some of the
relationships have been that Steve and I
went through those before me like
getting together because it only made us
so much more grateful and so much more
like knowing like I knew without a
shadow of a doubt that that's the one
and I think that's I wouldn't have known
had I not [ __ ] my legs doing that tingly
thing I just wouldn't became your
restless leg syndrome
like it's like pins and needles going
numb Steve always calls out his disease
Reza's leg syndrome doesn't exist and I
don't exist I know it does there's
commercials about it but I like to I
like to belittle him and I like to
invalidate his experience
okay I have to it is very serious
that's not real you're [ __ ] up cause
me a bully I was saying it I'm like I
wish I wish that every person that you
met came with like a CARFAX report for
the ones that have changed yeah updated
then you could google it like don't
don't talk this [ __ ] she lied to her
friends like two months ago or like
don't date this guy he punches people in
the face oh yeah there's like a day at
zero days since last plan to wear a sign
around your knees since last shorted
pants I go they don't want to date a
shorter put up with a shorter they has a
sense of humor I could deal with it I
think that's what I would tell my former
self is just like learn what is the most
of value in a relationship to you like
what do you personally value the most
and then don't settle because you know
some people for me it's like sense of
humor and you know stimulating
conversation and good sex but you know
like you could be broke as [ __ ] as some
people they like financial security or
something like that but you don't really
care if you have a personality
don't you dare subtle you find someone
that fits you good oh you know what I
would have told my younger self
save your money dude yeah honestly if
I could change anything it would be that
I would waste way less money I mean guys
if you're like in your early 20s don't
buy the brand new car buy the used car
don't spend all that you make I regret
that I that is my one regret
and like I said I [ __ ] blasted
through money dude I still refuse to buy
a new car like I'm still driving my cute
little like I still lease a cute little
Civic because cars are just like a
[ __ ] it's a it's a statement you know
it's just to show off to other people
and the moment it leaves the [ __ ]
line of depreciation value rarely lets
like a collector car whatever never ever
ever appreciates value I really say that
and I get a house or something like that
the first time so I'm really glad that I
grew up and learn how to be broke on my
own and struggled with bills on my own
because it makes you like appreciate
your money more but the first time I
started like making money was when I was
like 27 when I was like oh my god this
is the most money I've ever made ever
and I [ __ ] blew it all bad I traveled
everywhere like I don't regret the
travels I had so much fun I mean so many
memories which is great but then after
that I was just like and then like that
source of income it was like dude
advertising and all that stuff kind of
like went away because they weren't
doing advertisements anymore and then I
was like no yeah
it's like the lottery syndrome you had a
bunch of money and you blew it off
no yeah cuz we don't learn much
management before you get money it's
gonna go away
did you know this for me though like the
most like for me the the regret factor
when it comes to finances it's not even
like necessarily what I thought it was
mainly the fact that I purchased things
that I didn't really want because I was
trying to save a penny which ended up
going horrible waste that has been my
biggest regret like if I could go back
in time and be like just save up for the
quality [ __ ] cuz it's gonna last you
longer you're gonna love it you're gonna
like he's so happy with it and it's it's
it's literally gonna bring joy because
for me instead I would buy things where
I'm like oh like I really want that
thing but you know I'll settle for this
cheaper version
still gonna do the job and [ __ ] it it'll
be fine but then as I have this cheaper
thing I'm constantly hating it because
I'm like ah it's like not what I want
you know it just ends up being a big
gigantic waste of money so now that I'm
like I'm like on like wave 2 making
money again
I'm saving like an old Asian man yeah
like me 99% of my paycheck goes into my
savings good but I've also learned
throughout life that well personally for
me I learned that time is money and you
can always make money but you'll never
be able to you know take back time or
make time or anything so if I can save
time by like paying someone else to do
some of it I really really hate so I can
have the time to myself to do what I
want to do then I'll definitely indulge
it you can actually use that time to
make more money - if you wanted to or
inalienable crossing whatever right
right name switch it switch it off um my
biggest regret in that department
and again I try not to have any but like
when I was young like 18 I learned all
these money management principles I
learned how to manage money right I was
doing it correctly and I was like I'm
gonna be a millionaire by thirty because
I learned about compounding really I
know I was like - like although I was
like compounding interest I like I like
invested in stocks I tripled my money
within a few months like I was you know
yeah I was like really I was reading
everything I I thought I had it under
control
I was even an operating as an
independent contractor because I read
all about avoiding income tax and or at
least like me lowering it as much as
possible because that's really what
keeps people poor is [ __ ] income tax
due to wages yeah if you can't get to
get on that 1099 life and put away your
money like you're gonna have to set
aside a lot for taxes but pay yourself
first pay yourself at least ten percent
of your money before you give it to any
bills or any loans or anything like that
before you spend it on shopping or
anything then invest that savings in you
know split it up in long term
investments and then also having like a
high-yield savings account for liquidity
but I was doing all that
I live [ __ ] happened and breakups
happened worried like you were splitting
the bills 50/50 and Allison and you got
to cover the whole cost and I was like
[ __ ] and so I ended up pulling out all
of that money from the ayat the IRA that
I had started and you get penalized for
pulling it out early and then you I also
spent it all because on rent like on
like survival stuff but it took a while
to redevelop those habits and of course
when you shave off all those years of
like that I had already put in you can't
just pick back up at the place you left
off because it doesn't compound that way
so I'm like starting all over again to
Gina if you do something that I had no
idea about or cared about when I was 20
so let's just say like you know that's
almost 13 years ago Jesus Christ when I
was 20 Wow is is the concept of [ __ ] you
money so not being a slave to the job
that you're in or to the relationship
that you're in or whatever it is like
when you're in your 30s now it's kind of
like you want to be able to say this is
my life and I'm in control of it so I
don't have to keep this job if I don't
want it I don't have to keep this
relationship if I don't want it and
there's been times where I've kind of
put myself in a position where oh I got
a my first accounting job where I
started making a lot of money
I like bought a new car I bought all
this furniture on credit so I basically
I had like all these loans that I had to
pay every month and I could not quit my
job and I hated my very first boss he
was such a [ __ ] [ __ ] he made my
life a living hell
and I didn't have [ __ ] money I didn't
have anything in the savings account
because all I was just so overloaded
with debt immediately that I couldn't
[ __ ] leave that job and then or say a
relationship if you're not able to
afford anything and you're kind of stuck
in the relationship and you don't really
have anything and you can't get out of
it it's like you want to have [ __ ] you
money so you can do whatever you want my
20 year old self had no concept of that
she just said well let's just bring up
all the debt I'll be rich when I'm 30
I'll pay it all off it's fine it's not
fine save your money
yeah that and student loans man a lot of
people are feeling that
we like you know that's an investment
you think you're you know the old way
the old system was you go to college you
in that that investment is gonna pay off
because you're gonna get a job that's
gonna pay off those loans and then
you'll be making a much better income
but that's just not how this works
anymore
something like sometimes I'm like oh man
I wish I went to college but then I see
if I was struggling with student loans
are like good I'm a huge fan of learning
learning education be reading books be
all constantly learning constantly
curious girl get your ass on my leg
without like standing up and showing you
guys I'm wearing boxers do a Japanese
meal Cheeta you're a mess tell us the
truth I don't like anal I think 40 year
old Gina needs to come and talk to 30
okay what is 40 year old do you know get
your [ __ ] together [ __ ] credit though
we've done an episode on credit before
on hey [ __ ] I would have told my
younger self do not trust him
he will not pay off that [ __ ] credit
card bill and you'll be stuck with it
and it's gonna be a negative mark on
your credit report for years to come
girl oh my god credit score oh yeah that
is me I never [ __ ] was when I was
younger it was so I'm really proud I've
never actually been in debt ever no ways
the only debt I've ever had to think
when I least my car and I just have to
pay that off whatever that's fine but
I'm really proud because I when I was
younger see here this is where ignorance
is bliss I'm telling you guys this right
now I didn't understand credit cards
until I was like 20 maybe 21 this one
yeah that's so pretty all right
and then
so I was like and that the concept of it
was like I don't want to use money that
I don't have that makes no sense I was
always scared of it and then my friend
always told me like bro like you you
need to build credit and that's how I
card but before that I never had one so
I never like spent any credit and his
painting back but also I was looking at
a cosigner for my first car and I just
paid everything off so when I opened up
a credit card they're like oh yeah like
decent credit I'm like from [ __ ]
lawyer like I didn't yeah yeah so that's
one thing though that I'm really proud
of I stayed out of debt I never had debt
ever do you have a credit card now I do
I have a cobia okay good because you do
need that's the whole freaking catch-22
of it all because you you need credit
card to build credit because having no
credit is not good either yeah I mean we
did an episode on it so listen to that
episode but once you learn that system
you can actually use it to your
advantage and get a lot of free [ __ ] by
just like putting things that you would
normally spend your cash on anyway like
your groceries gas utilities things that
like you're already paying for put it on
the credit card pay it right away and
then you get collect the some points go
to places for free
mm-hmm that's what I've been doing to
like I really put anything on my debit
card anymore everything it just goes on
my credit card and then at the end I
just look at all my pointy like Sephora
points yeah yeah I never use my points
either and I'm like I should probably
use these there's a lot usually yours
expiring plankton I know my credit card
they don't expire but oh one of my
credit cards the rewards expires at the
end of each year whack yeah also at you
what about like the smaller things that
you would tell yourself like well I've
actually was poking your eyebrows so
thin that was me dude I have the foot
control eyebrows don't follow any trends
if it's a trend that's gonna leave a
long lasting effect on your face oh yeah
don't let me do it well all the girls
now are following the fillers trend and
that's gonna leave a permanent that's
that's true
gonna be their thin eyebrows like the
wrong they look so oh I know they go
from working 16 to like 35 insolently
because their face is still like
developing your face is still developing
and they put too much and they turn into
like a pillow face so you're just
thinking it's all puffy and weird I'm
like this like this like there's like a
sweet spot where you put a little bit so
it looks good if you pass out she's like
now for me I think the beauty tip I'd
give myself is like look Tiffany I know
I [ __ ] know you're too lazy for this
I get it
older tip would love you even more if
you just [ __ ] remove your makeup
every night literally kick on makeup
like yeah it was nasty
it was [ __ ] nasty it's that the other
thing that I'd like beg my younger self
is please please please please wear
sunscreen sunscreen oh so many sunspots
no antler-like because your chest is
like one of the first things to wrinkle
your hands in your chest and I did not
wear sunscreen because I was like I
don't get sunburned so I trust hands
neck those are the four things are give
away your age immediately and better get
all these people all the time like
everyone asked me Gina was just given
care of it seemed like dude the first
thing you need to worry about just
putting on sunscreen and like even you
have to worry even when you're in the
house and you go out because there is
great over there your computer you need
certain SPF to block that blue screen
Irish skin and I don't
oh my god super goop has the best
sunscreen that I was like getting mad at
worth it
okay so I was gon get the Korean or
Japanese ones cuz you know how they're
[ __ ] crazy about their sunscreens and
their skincare and stuff I've been
literally in Korean how do you know what
to buy
yes me hello I'm asking I have like a
[ __ ] the whole collection of
sunscreen I buy like eight at a time and
then they just found recently felt like
this tinted one - it's really good - I'm
crazy dude
that one time when we all went on a trip
and it was we were all hanging out by
the pool yeah who's got sunburn
like I noticed that my my body got a
little bit burnt because I was trying to
tan but my face they perfectly fine I'm
telling you man I got your sunscreen
needs dang and then another thing to
Vitamix yeah vitamins well I did not
realize that it affects your mental
state - like it's not just your body or
whatever cuz when you're young you're
like I don't [ __ ] care I just eat
Triscuits and I [ __ ] party whatever
that's what mom's awkward to you when
you come over after school yeah I needed
it to feel like home
always always rub the [ __ ] out of like
around my eyes like for some reason I
had an idea that if I scrubbed hard
enough the darkness under my dark
circles will go away oh no and it would
just like my entire like the skin all
around my eyes it's like a little like
super thin very like part of your face
okay neat when it comes to vitamins what
were the huge benefits that you felt
okay so for me personally and I can't
speak for everyone on this but I was
chronically deficient in vitamin D and B
and D and I am currently deficient in
vitamin D in so I found out that like I
was going running every day like wig in
the Sun for 30 minutes a day like I was
like how the hell am I still deficient
and I was I was even taking supplements
and I found out that my birth control
was blocking absorption or at least
that's what I think it is because that
was the one variable when I got off
birth control I
stop being chronically deficient in it
and it improved like for me it was mood
swings
I could not out like I'd be fine for
like when I woke up I was fine and
everything was happy and then we just
dip into like [ __ ] craziness and I
had no control at all and like I still
get waves of that for sure like hormonal
II and like sometimes just general
depression but this was like crazy like
every day was like a scrambled egg mess
and now it's like an omelet and so
sometimes there's a mess but it's like a
very emotional woman you know at least
my hair was pretty and why was that Jess
why do you because you're used function
of beauty Nikki that's it this is my
favorite shampoo I've talked about in a
million times this is my I've finally
almost ran out of this one before I did
I ordered another one hey yeah and this
is the conditioner that I have if you
guys haven't heard function of beauty is
like our favorite shampoo and
conditioner one size fits all may work
for your accessories but when it comes
to your hair we need something a little
different so function of beauty will
create any type of shampoo basically
that you need based on your hair needs
it's very customizable it's super simple
you go online you take a really quick
quiz you just say like what your problem
areas are and they create a custom
shampoo and conditioner for you cuts
them all the way down to this the scent
and the color of it I get purple views
I'm on it yeah and it puts your name on
it I wonder if I can get this close to
the what scent did you get can you see
it it's so spunctional-- Jessica it
might be blurry but oh my god Jessica
yes just had this on a scent in the
shampoo but I got a scent in the
conditioner this time I got the peach
one mmm but I think I'm gonna try them
what is it the Mentors yeah you make you
one right look at eucalyptus I'm gonna
try that one next I'm not just gonna try
all of them I'm gonna keep the same
formula for my hair because it's it's
actually helping my bleached hair to
survive but I'm just gonna change the
scent each time and see what
I just got lavender I'd had eucalyptus
and it was amazing and it made your head
feel tingly and smooth and then now I
just got lavender and they're both
relaxing that's awesome
I wanted you to put the bottle up to the
camera and I wanted to smell it but it
doesn't work so guys their formulas are
vegan and cruelty-free they never use
sulfates parabens or any other harmful
ingredients this is the internet's top
rated haircare brand with over 40,000
five-star reviews and Counting so what
are you waiting for go to function of
beauty calm slash big mood to take your
4 part hair profile quiz and save 20% on
your first order that is go to a
function of beauty calm slash big mood
for 20% off and let them know you heard
about it from our show that is function
of beauty calm slash big mood I actually
used our 20% code myself recently I
didn't do that I should I don't know why
I'd forgot to code I paid full price
yeah and also along with all the things
I would tell my younger self would be to
be healthy and incorporate healthy
habits into your life and Noom is an app
that helps you not only lose weight or
help you hit those goals or whatever
your health goals might be but also the
psychological aspect of forming healthy
habits and what I really like is
everyone has different goals and so this
is also not a one-size-fits-all like
your hair it you everyone has different
goals everyone has different body types
everyone has different health issues and
so you put all that in your assigned of
goal specialist and you're matched up
with a community of numerous so there's
always support and people going through
the same things as you are you can
really just like relate to other people
you have you put in your specific goals
you want to achieve or or if you have
achieved with new like physically eating
better to feel better psychologically
feeling good about your choices or
improve sense of self-worth or social I
didn't even think about this one but a
lot of a lot of times
because I get kind of a little bit of
anxiety when I go into a social
situation I found that I would reach for
whatever snacks were there or or drinks
or whatever and I would just be glued to
that all night I felt like I had to have
something that I was putting into my
mouth all night and new helps you break
habits like that because you identify
like what is causing that behavior so
it's really cool you're assigned with a
specialist and it Noom doesn't demand
much of your time they only ask for ten
minutes a day super easy
there's a science to getting healthier
it's called Noom so sign up for your
trial today at noon and oom comm slash
big mood what do you have to lose visit
new mom slash big mood to start your
trial today that's Noom n-o-o-o m.com
slash big mood pigma yeah yay all right
so we went over love we went over money
we went over beauty oh wait love though
oh yeah
I wanted to tell my younger self we need
to school these younger selves in love
oh my beautiful Tiffany you were so
delicate you beautiful flower oh I wish
I could tell you this but for me like
pert like I had and we talked about like
my insecurities and stuff in in the last
episode and like why they happened but
the one advice I wish I could tell
myself is like don't doubt that you're
strong enough to be alone I really felt
like I was too weak and I needed to be
in a relationship in order to survive or
something and and I really I actually
got this like like subconsciously
ingrained in me through women and my
family a lot of women just stayed in
relationships they don't want to be in
and I just put up with a lot of abuse or
whatever it was because they felt like
that was their only choice and so I
think like for a few of my early
relationships that's the same mentality
that I had where I was just like well
this is just the way it is I guess I
gotta put up with it and I wish I could
just tell myself like no girl you're
[ __ ] strong you are beautiful you
just got to focus on yourself and like
internally love yourself and know that
you can make it on your own
matter what so yeah yeah that's
something I forgot about like cuz I
would think I would still do every
single relationship but some of them I
definitely dragged out longer than I
needed to I think that fear of being
alone or the in-between will make you
drag things out longer but also at the
same note dragging something out super
long and like taking a relationship an
extra two or three years beyond what you
really should have been in it it kind of
also helps to like to learn a little bit
about yourself and like what you really
don't want when you are alone and things
like that so it's really hard yeah a lot
of people have the fears of like
especially the longer it gets it's like
well I already spent this much time you
know I don't want to start over cuz it's
like you felt like you invested so much
time already but if it's not working
it's not working and it's not gonna get
like better if just by depositing more
time in the bank yeah so yeah yeah
exactly and a lot of people I'm
surprised um
don't give themselves that that like
time to be alone and like really
discover who they are and you know
taking your experience from whatever
relationship you just went through like
you need to sometimes you just need to
process that and like discover like what
you liked about it what you didn't like
about it like have some assessment about
it know like where you stand and what
your boundaries are and it definitely
makes you much stronger and um knowing
what you do want in your next
relationship there's there's a part to
that too I think like when I would be in
a relationship and I would maybe I'm
trying to be trying to get out of it and
I would maybe kind of go out to a bar to
a club or something when I was younger
and I would kind of look around and be
like Oh could I date anyone else like
just trying to see what's out there to
kind of give me the motivation to leave
and I wouldn't find anything right away
so I would stay right I'm like well
there's nothing better out there but
also one thing that I didn't really
realize is when you're young your life
experience is this short so like you
basically go off of like just a tiny bit
of experience to make your judgment call
but now after dating so for two decades
now I I know that like there is another
person that I can get close to or closer
to than this current guy because I used
to think like well
never like have as much in common with
someone as yes person but it's like you
you date more and more people and you
realize you can have like even better
connections or Dan or guys will treat
you better it's not just like oh this
one guy happens to be really great but
you're only 22 he's not the only one but
it feels like he's the only one so you
just like won't leave or you get scared
because like you're like well who is who
is even better and in their current life
you're like I don't see anybody better
through breakups like if you're in their
breakup musical because the best person
ever like I always sound like if you
think this one's good imagine how
[ __ ] great it would be when you find
the actual one that's been for you you
know what I mean hmm yeah it's it's the
one that doesn't make you long for
anything else there's no area where
you're like I long for people in the
world
sure just Center what there's options
there's options that yeah it just sucks
at the moment you leave I'm not for me I
stayed in a lot of relationships not I
mean not because I felt like that person
was like it for me it was actually
because I felt like I I kind of got
trapped in like commitment with like his
family or with my family and like
whatever expectations were laid out
where it's like oh you know you guys are
an item and that's just what it is and
I'm like how do I get out of this now
[ __ ] I feel you know this serious
relationship I ever left was a five-year
one where I felt like really close to
his family and like all that was
intertwined and he was a good guy like
he tried treated me nice so I felt like
sort of I felt like an [ __ ] for
leaving but I just didn't feel any
passion like at all and and for me I was
like man I'm am I ever gonna find anyone
that gets me the way that he gets me and
makes me feel comfortable and safe and
like isn't nice because there's a lot of
[ __ ] dicks out there and I don't like
I'm I got scared at but you know
something did just didn't feel right I
couldn't picture spending the next you
know 60 years with
or whatever it is like and if at the end
of the day if getting married is
spending the rest of your life with
somebody I just didn't see myself being
happy settling on that and that was the
scariest one because it's like there's
nothing wrong there and I like this
family and it's all comfortable but yeah
I would tell my younger self do it yes
yeah do it yeah and also move on and
also if another piece of advice is if
you're getting mixed signals then just
take it as a no oh yeah like especially
early in dating like if the guy's not
kind of showing up consistently it's
like unless you're Steve and you fell
asleep
dude I was I told him straight up I'm
detaching because I fell hard right away
and so did he like we on our first date
we both were like I'm gonna marry this
person but then little things happen
we're like yeah he fell asleep when he
said he was on his way over to my house
and I never heard from him the rest of
the night couldn't get ahold of him and
I was like this [ __ ] just stood
me up I thought I was in love and then I
just got stood up I told him I was I
think communications also big key and
relationships but like I didn't hold
that grudge I don't like holding grudges
I like to just nip things in the bud but
I told him hey I was really developing
strong feelings for you and if this is
how you're gonna be then I need to
detach because I can't be putting my
100% out there and then only getting 50%
back and he [ __ ] shaped up
immediately he was like that was a
mistake I would never do that again like
he was very used on it he never never
happened again and that's how you build
trust is like if someone tells you that
was a mistake and you give them that
trust and then they never break it again
then you're like okay you're to be
trusted and that's how that builds yeah
actions so yeah when it comes down to
stuff like that like is if you ever sit
there like oh so does this like don't
get too attached and just kind of take
it as a no and most of the time if you
take it as a no and started treating him
in that way they come crawling back
yes chasing when you like stop giving a
[ __ ] so that's why you have to set that
boundary you have to put the line in the
sand and say this is where I'm I'm
bringing the table Gina this table table
thing to have this idea where it's like
at least in my experience um I hope it's
not the truth all across the board but
in my experience a lot of guys seem to
have the idea like the [ __ ] you treat
a girl the more likely she's gonna be
with you or stay with you and I'm like
immature ass [ __ ] yeah yeah that's
like that gets young girls young young
inexperienced girls once you start
reaching like the older more experienced
if you have women donuts I know that him
yeah if you just women like there's like
more experienced women they're just not
gonna put up with that like dude are you
kidding me and it's I remember hearing
because my mom had told me that said
women [ __ ] who they want men [ __ ] who
they can I mean they have a lot of
options yeah we actually do we have like
so many but it's like there's no if you
start training them like that they're
not really gonna do good for a long time
yeah yeah it's all about what you want
you know the timing of two people
knowing what they want and finding each
other yeah I feel the same way with
friends don't you because I feel oh yeah
when I was younger I was so bummed I
didn't have a group of friends and I I
totally relate to that still but where
I'm like I'm glad I did find a group of
friends but at that time you know I was
like man I really want friends and I
feel like I would have been friends with
anybody and instead of like the people
that I that really mean something or
that I feel like fit my same values and
and goals and beliefs and all that stuff
and so I think I'm actually more
grateful that I didn't have that that
group of friends yet because some of the
people I see that did have like that
group of friends
they they're trying to grow and like
their group of friends isn't growing
with them and it kind of they're kind of
like crabs in a bucket and they pull
each other down and that's like in a
small town mentality comes yeah a lot
and they almost feel obligated to their
old friends just because they've been
friends for so long and they can't have
conversations with them I can't say it
talked about certain things I really
like I'm literally one of those people
for sure like I have a breath that I've
known my entire life and it's just like
we grew apart and it's just really hard
because you have that like loyalty oh
yeah like you know of length of time
that we've known each other and how much
we've been through with each other but
in the end it's like we're not really
like the best for each other
it's very interesting cuz I'm like I'll
meet new friends or all date someone and
then I always hear them say something
like oh like I'll meet a friend like oh
yeah you know he's cool but like he does
his big dick kid he's gonna Brody talks
[ __ ] about all of us I was like why are
you still friends with this person you
know but she's like well you know we've
been friends for so long I just like no
dude I don't think it really matters
like if I was friends with someone for
like a decade and I found out they were
a raging homophobe or racism nothing
sticking around just cuz we've been
together for so long so I'm gonna call
you on your [ __ ] not be friends with you
anymore
you know right exactly and I think um I
don't know about you Gina but I feel
like I only developed that from like
kind of being alone and getting to know
myself and where what I'm willing to put
up with and not willing to put up with
and you know where I set that bar and I
that comes with a little bit of
experience of dealing with people and
dealing with different friendships and
having to break up with certain friends
and stuff but ultimately I feel like you
know knowing that first and then finding
your circle helps you know keep quality
friends yeah I mean I I mean I have
friends that I thought were like in my
early to as they go yeah we're gonna be
each other's weddings I want to grow old
together and yell at children in our
lawn and then a couple years you can
only grow apart you realize
oh you know like this isn't what I want
in a friendship anymore you know and
that's okay like it doesn't have to buy
out like the shitty way just a mcli
amicably kind of clear own way yeah and
then I think like that the years have
also learned that um a small group of
close friends is way better than a
[ __ ] huge group of mm-hmm
I'd rather know you three ninety percent
then no like 20 different girls in a
huge group maybe like twenty percent
early it's 50 percent yeah like
sometimes don't look at people's wedding
photos like how the [ __ ] you have 16
bridesmaids half of those girls like
during the battery charity we're talking
[ __ ] they were like not getting they
were [ __ ] being can't caddy or
whatever yeah so how's it feel like big
groups of friends and stuff no I mean
even that like so on our wedding like
none of you were there and that sucks
because I felt like you know we didn't
have a big group of friends either but
we had like a large group of
acquaintances and then we had like we
could only invite I had 90 people in my
family and then Steve had 30 people in
his family so that was already yeah and
so so we only had I got a like a friend
list of like 20 so it was just people
that we had seen in that and that year
and spent the most time with but yeah
like there's a lot of people that I feel
like I didn't develop that circle that
tight circle of friends until after we
got married and I wish that you guys
would have been able to be there if I oh
well that's one regret like if I could
go back to five years younger Nikki I
would be like just invite everybody cuz
like there I knew you guys I just did we
just hadn't like hung hung out yet yeah
and there was a lot of people like that
where like I I didn't know who to put up
keep on the list and not and I was
always told like oh you don't want it to
get more than 150 people or else it gets
[ __ ] crazy and we're like well we
don't have that much
or whatever but there ended up being so
much more extra seats and there was like
buffet styles so there was extra food
and I'm just like [ __ ] I wish I had
invited everybody I wanted to be there
yeah
yes it was it would have been it would
been fun I mean it was still fun but it
would have been fun to have you guys in
the pictures and memories and stuff yeah
he was like right before it was like
right before before like we got really
tight with JK yeah yeah it's like for me
my adulthood is actually the most amount
of friends that I would say like I would
consider like oh yeah this is my group
you know yeah but yeah like growing up
it was just like me and two of the girls
and [ __ ] ton of acquaintances but not
really like like super super tight kind
of kind of stuff I think that's why
people like paife to be in a sorority
and stuff like cuz they like just really
want to have their group and they just
don't already have it and they want to
make sure they get it yeah you know I
think it would stress me out too much
just being around that many people you
know what you can do though if you're so
stressed
what and you want to talk to somebody or
talk to somebody imagine you're in your
sorority and you just [ __ ] hey you're
gonna say Becky Jess Jessica that was it
and so it Jessica never ever uses
Jessica as the annoying girl's name
right
I think Brittany Brittany's Lucas the
way you say it's just like Jessica but a
stressed out if you guys have this have
something going on your life and he's
gonna talk to somebody about it let me
tell you about talk space so talk space
is a mobile like you therapy up talking
helps everyone knows that it's an online
therapy app that is here to help you to
do just that so what you do is go in you
take a little quiz like okay what do you
want to work on you know what do you
want out of this do you have a history
of this is this very simple quiz
Matthieu the budget therapist licensed
therapist real ones and then you choose
which one you want to talk to you and it
shows all of their credentials and
everything - how long they've been
practicing
what's like what schools you went to you
know and you can give this board that
you need on whatever's going to works
for you because your therapist is there
24/7 on your phone or your computer and
you'll hear back daily a lot of times
they check your phone quite a few times
a day to respond to you it's also really
really affordable one month untuk space
costs about the same amount as a single
in-person therapy session so that's one
month of messaging than whatever you
want and they talk to you every day back
and that's like way awesome because I
remember when I started this I was broke
as [ __ ] but with rock space you know you
can send them it's unlimited messages
that means you never have to wait
shields on your mind possibly therapists
have experienced treating depression
anxiety substance abuse trauma
relationship issues food and eating food
and eating and much more talks place is
secure in private using the latest
encryption technology to store client
information it's also not only through
text sometimes some people really like
to have face-to-face contact you can
also video chat with them you can do a
voice chat with and see if you don't
want to type so if you guys are one of
those people you can definitely call and
talk to them in person whenever you need
we all need to talk sometimes and
hospice gives us the support we deserve
at price we can afford match with your
perfect carapace at top space calm all
right download the app use promo code
mood to get $100 off your first month
and help support the show that's $1 off
$100 that's a lot of dollars hey that's
a lot of doll hairs I personally use or
coke that's once again talk space calm
criminal code mood for $100 off your
first one that's right and if you care
about your appearance like I do
you should check out candid Co which is
we're aligners delivered straight to
your door and so the CAD candid
treatment includes remote remote
monitoring by your orthodontists
throughout your entire treatment so you
never have to wonder where you are and
your treatment and if you have a special
event coming up the average treatment
length with candid Co is just six months
so you'll start seeing results way
before then and so you can get your
beautiful straight teeth and all in the
comfort of your own home because they
deliver these clear aligners and so it's
also a fraction of the cost it's
significantly more affordable then if
you would be going to an authority
dontist in person especially with times
like these like you know all this like
stuff happening in the world is just a
lot more difficult and a lot more
complicated for you to actually go in
person to see orthodontist so candid Co
is a great alternative to that so are
you ready to take the first step towards
straighter teeth for a limited time you
can get started with $75 off by using
code mood that's m oo D at candid co.com
slash mood handed co.com slash mood news
code mood for $75 off candid co.com
slash mood code mood get a beautiful
luscious straight smile
oh yeah that's something I would say is
[ __ ] floss I got so many cavities they
were so expensive like because when I'm
a kid and I get cavities like my parents
all right I'm on their insurance I don't
worry about the bills or whatever would
they like whittier an adult and then you
to pay for your own [ __ ] oh yeah
fillings are so expensive and I always
got them in between my teeth because I
just didn't know and then I was made in
flossing uh it's like a must like it's a
non-negotiable I have to floss morning
and night and I haven't gotten cavities
yeah and yours is one thing I tell
younger meatsuit
your [ __ ] teeth and wear your
retainer is you dumb [ __ ] oh yeah [ __ ]
after paying for that seriously one
thing I have done consistently since I
was younger that I would say that I'm
proud that I have done and I would tell
my younger self to make sure to stay
even though she did it already so I
don't think she needs this advice but
anyway to tell my younger self or or
encourage anyone else to start working
out get into fitness in your early teens
in high school as possible or at start
as soon as possible because I barely
even really have to work out now and my
body is [ __ ] stays amazing such a
wake up I don't know just like the
musculoskeletal system that I've built
and maintained throughout this whole
time like I could I can lose weight
super easy now
like when I go to the gym it's not like
this whole thing so like if you can in
your teens or in your 20s like start
working out start lifting weights
females to start lifting weights like
just get in the gym and stay forever
make it a lifestyle you will take this
out true I would tell my younger self
like [ __ ] get over yourself it's not
[ __ ] weird for some reason I felt
like working out was embarrassing you
think that people are watching you maybe
maybe it was that's why I'm like get
over yourself girl cuz I really felt
like even now it's kind of like it's
lessened a lot but still I still have
like the underlining like weirdness
about it like if I'm working at home
like I can't have like casey nearby or i
don't know i have to be alone i can't do
like isis because then for some reason i
feel ok that everyone else around me is
doing the same thing but it's really
young like in PE and stuff you know what
maybe it was like like ingrained in me
that like working out was lame because
during PE classes like whoever was
actually doing the exercises in my
school we like they would get made fun
out like maybe that's right honey
wait so you weren't any sports in high
school right cuz like i knew i in sports
like you were cool if you were actually
doing well at the sport but i guess it's
like the people that didn't take actual
sports that were just like stuck in PE
there oh yeah it really was like even
it's like you know we have to like run
the by or whatever I want literally
everyone would be walking and whoever
was actually running the mile
they'd be like loser and all this stuff
like they would get it makes no sense to
kids are such [ __ ]
yeah because like they'll find it's just
random things to make fun of people for
like oh you have a regular pencil [ __ ]
dude with exercise I was like I was one
of those people in the mile that always
likes either skip the mile or I would
like just walk like the same pace ever
but then senior year after I got [ __ ]
dumped two weeks before prom I was like
I'm gonna I'm gonna work out like a
[ __ ] I'm gonna be in the gym
every day I'm gonna get so hot and I got
obsessed with nutrition and with working
out to the point of like everything
needed to be perfect and like I I was
overdoing it like way overdoing I was
like in the gym like two hours a day
eating [ __ ] just like tofu and
broccoli and like that's it and like and
he's like high protein no carbs zero
carbs and um yeah I got like I got to
the point where like I would not only do
strength training because I was I had
read about like how muscle burns weren't
the fad and like I gotta build muscle
and all stuff and I got to the point
where like it deeply ingrained in me
that walking didn't count low intention
like low intensity exercises didn't
count and so like when when I didn't
have time to do a full workout I was
like oh I should just go on a walk I'd
be like that doesn't count I might as
well do nothing and so I just didn't I
didn't even walk or anything you do have
this like very unhealthy association
with not only working out but nutrition
as well yeah yeah idiot Lee like
immediately just like got really
obsessive and like overboard yeah and I
didn't get better until last year when I
was healing my gut health with SIBO that
I so this whole time whole time
I know that yeah I was doing workout
programs and I would like hit it hard I
was going to Barry's bootcamp I'd maybe
sometimes double up and go to cardio bar
like it had to be high-intensity
workouts or nothing so I was very hot
with that cuz I felt like if it wasn't
if I wasn't doing 100% that I might as
well be doing 0% cuz it that's never
never never true I know and I just got a
just got really like ingrained in me
just perfectionist wiesen and then when
I actually saw a nutritionist she's like
you're stressing yourself out so much
yeah you're just upset yeah because I
actually gained weight when I was trying
when I was doing all of that to like my
wedding dress and stuff I actually
gained weight and like probably it
enhanced those gut health problems that
were already there because the stress
did not help and it's really bad for
your digestive system if you're
constantly stressed out it's a marathon
not a sprint
it's literally a lifestyle it sounds so
ridiculous
but when it really is a lifestyle but
you don't have to be that like that
doesn't have to be your personality so
for people that are like well I don't
want to be like all those fitness
[ __ ] you know like you don't have to
be that I'm not that like I'm you never
see me post about fitness stuff I like
once you know in the past year really
but like I've always worked out I've
worked out since very very young and um
you know even going for a walk around
the neighborhood get a dog but like make
that force you to stay fit you know we
all have cats girl like yeah we'll skip
the mile cuz we're late yeah I wish I
got into that fitness kick like there's
some people who just suddenly I don't
know they're like it's my life now like
you know good for you yeah see I know
what do you know for uh for me new it
kind of like it's not all bad because we
danced a lot when we were younger we did
not exercise any form of exercise is
healthy it doesn't have to be a gym my
cardio was so good back that I saw the
likes from Dancing to thank God but I
really I I guess I didn't count that
either cuz I was a dancer from hmm
2:24 yeah dude but I just didn't I
didn't count it because it was like
exercise has to be hard and it has to be
like you have to feel a burden and I yet
though like feel like like a hardcore
[Laughter]
you didn't do anything it was fun so
we're talking to last year Niki actually
not it was like 20 years old that's when
this mentality started so if I could go
back I'd be like hey just [ __ ] don't
it's like yeah yeah yeah yeah and then
and then that like leads into like
mental health wise and and spirituality
wise I just feel like like [ __ ] rest
is what I would tell myself because I
don't know why I feel like it has to be
all or nothing like I burned myself up
burn the candle at both ends or I won't
even light the candle and you could have
like balance you know like you can
schedule rest and then schedule work
like you don't have to give up all
luxuries just because you need I have a
funny question okay so you know how
we're talking about like giving advice
to our younger selves what's like a
sex-related
advising you it like that you wish you
knew but you might it all wrong we're
let me tell you oh my god so [ __ ] so
like Asian people we never have a talk
and they're not very well educated when
it comes to sex health like my stepmom
at the time my previous that mom thought
that the way to clean your vagina is
literally makes warm water in a giant
bowl like a giant the plastic ones that
the Asian people use pour like the
douche solution in there and I just sit
in it wait to just dilute it even more
yeah she was [ __ ] stupid then that's
why they're not married anymore anyways
do solution whatever it's like vinegar
it's like very diluted vinegar yeah you
never supposed to do SH period yeah so
she figured it would be cleaning just
like put it in warm water just sitting
there and I never understood this so one
also like what like you're literally
just like it's not gonna go in and I was
like 8 years old 8 years also need to
clean out their vagina - sadly asian
people are very like oh you know the
Chinese are very like it's like it's
like a weird sacred thing but also if
you're on your period don't walk in
front of the Buddhist shrine because
that's I don't know like they're [ __ ]
weird about this yeah so like I was
never taught any of that growing up like
you know like you will get bacterial
infections will get yeast infections
from like because I used to take a lot
of baths when I was younger like in my
teenage years or like I'm using the
wrong soap like I used to music shampoo
to clean you know and then like and
third you never taught any of these
things and then like for the longest
time I thought oh my genders just
supposed to smell like that you just
have a lot of Miss charged along really
years I thought that was just normal and
so I got old enough to like take myself
to the doctor to get everything checked
out I got on like birth control and then
when I went and they like the gaming
exam examination
they're like bro that's like it back to
you infection like Indiana not drinking
water are you worried underwear this too
tight for you or something and like oh I
don't know do you think on the girls of
the internet now like we didn't really
have like anyone to just straight-up
ask like yeah now that you could just
Google anything like is it normal that
my vagina is leaking this much right so
then they gave me medication and then
when it was all cleared up I was like
how do you
this is crazy yeah you don't like I want
the memory because I am vagina problems
when I was a kid and I had no idea like
randomly it would just hurt really bad
and yeah and it like we couldn't figure
out what it was like my mom thought it
maybe it was a yeast infection and like
we went to the doctor and he basically
had me take acidophilus which is like a
probiotic so like because I remember
having to learn the word acidophilus
tasted nasty you know we have to make it
yeah and then it ended up being
something with or at least I don't know
if this was it but when we stopped doing
it the problems seemed to go away but
the fragrance in in soaps and stuff for
me I guess I just had a really sensitive
but Dinah yeah like it didn't like when
I had that like fragrant 'add show and
so after we stopped using that and like
it was just more natural soap and I was
taking my acidophilus it went away but
yeah I if there was a whole chunk of my
childhood were like my vagina would
really hurt and questioning me she's
like did anyone touch yeah I didn't know
what you're talking about cuz I was
young and like we hadn't had any of
those talks yet and so I was like no
like who would touch me they're like
that's crazy yeah yeah good idea was the
cost of patient I had cost of patient
problems as a kid and I didn't know what
it was and then like I literally lived
through just pain for so long feel like
it just feels like a like a ball and
your intestine and it just like it
cramps and it hurts and like I would
always just be like oh my stomach hurts
and then for some reason also I was just
so embarrassed to even talk about poop
and so like I remember my mom would be
like have you proved it I'm like oh my
god no just like I don't know who but I
don't work out
and I don't boo like mom oh my god like
we're just like eating straight Cheetos
like why couldn't dude I don't know but
it was literally constipated for a good
chunk of my childhood like oh you're so
stressed about embarrassed yeah like and
then yeah and then like I was always so
afraid to like poop in the house when
anyone was around like I had some weird
problems yeah like psychological issues
I don't know where that that for sure I
don't know where that came from
that's one thing I would tell my younger
self my 20 ish self is to wear condoms
with every single guy cuz I got
chlamydia in college and that was not
fun it's like it's basically the same
thing as having like a bacterial
infection so if you've ever had like BV
or whatever it's kind of it feels the
same it's just like some [ __ ] nasty
[ __ ] comes out and it's kind of painful
I mean yeah like like whatever white
[ __ ] or whatever yellow [ __ ] is charge
yeah I think you know like a yeast
infection yeah but well but but it
smells when it's when it's bacterial it
smells yeah yeast infection usually
doesn't so but yeah like dude I [ __ ] man
yeah I use condoms girls frozen boys I
got HPV which there is some there's a
hundred strains of HPV so it doesn't
automatically well I said this on the JK
news and I was surprised at how many
people were like ignorant about HPV and
looks because our generation didn't we
didn't have the vaccine
like everyone behind us has gotten the
vaccine so it's like a non-factor
anymore that makes sense it's like our
generation was like one in three we were
the last generations were like everyone
[ __ ] got it that makes sense yeah and
but we I used a condom and even I got it
oh yeah yeah what's the same with herpes
you just you can't stop even with
condoms you can still get herpes so
that's crazy
yes I got checked for HPV oh really
where you probably got it everyone our
age I think
Tex as part of it let's see now
well nothing ever showed up station
knows it doesn't automatically mean
words no no way miss Sara Lee is weird
okay yeah there's like zero symptoms
I've had it since I was 18 I've had zero
symptoms I don't know why I knew was
because they when they did the pap smear
they said I had priests or precancerous
cells or something and then yeah it's
scariest [ __ ] you're like same with me
that's what they said I've definitely
gotten exams like often and if your pap
is normal then you could just have one
that's dormant and it's our age and all
the girls our age have it wasn't gonna
say okay so every time you've gotten STD
checks and it's always negative or
whatever you've never gotten an abnormal
pap smear because that's what I plucked
up for me like they were like oh you
have this like abnormality in your
cervix or whatever and then I was like
yeah might have always just been like BV
or like slight very slightly some very
um very um cones these infections
because I drink like two drops of water
a month so alcohol sugar alcohol if
anyone YouTube [ __ ] should be
concerned about alcohol I got my first
decent affection this year oh dang and
on that note for tuning in to be they
think you listening to talk about our
vagina problems for another episode
yeah that was all perhaps ya know like
oh that's my needed advice
oh you mean like sexual acts because
mine was like oh yeah okay so we have
we'll have another episode about the
sexual things we wish you would have
learned yeah my last parting advice is
always be learning always be curious and
don't have regrets no regrets no regrets
no to be nice to yourself yes love
yourself
[Applause]
samples of stuff that we like merch
thank you and this was one of the
samples that was sent in and then
quarantine happened and so I was like
well I just had an idea how cute would
it be if we had like a March website but
it breaks down by name each of us and
each of us has designed a thing because
we all have different like styie
my first thought goes to um what if no
one buys mine
it's okay someone's gonna buy the Nikki
leave over I'll buy it I'll get my dad
to buy one that are like has one color
tag on the incidences please buy this
horrible cry your purchase has saved a
tear from thank you so much for saving
my brother side of the deal with this
love Steve Steve is the one that doesn't
want to deal with the blowback he's
alright another thing we might be in the
set pretty soon again guys
look out for maybe no more Zuma bacilli
maybe one is starting to open soon
so we're gonna be maybe possibly doing
that yeah yeah I like your nails TIFF
who did your nails I'm just kidding
it's probably enemies [ __ ] me [ __ ]
did I